además de esas cifras récords de
contagios diarios el país reportó 140
muertes por kobe 19 y 8 mil personas
están hospitalizadas por kobe 19 en todo
el reino unidos lo que significa un
aumento del 4% con respecto a la semana
pasada lo cierto es que la población
cada vez más está haciendo más pruebas
de kobe 19 caseras siguiendo los
consejos de los expertos porque en este
país este tipo de pruebas son gratis y
disponibles para todas las personas que
así lo quieran lo cierto es que los
casos aquí en el reino unido están
creciendo como un tsunami los casos de
omicron especialmente y aunque los
expertos han pedido que se impongan
nuevas restricciones el primer ministro
boris johnson las ha descartado antes de
navidad pero se ha reservado ese derecho
posiblemente para después lo cierto es
que johnson está viviendo una crisis de
autoridad y de credibilidad si tratará
de imponer nuevas restricciones ni su
partido ni su gobierno lo apoyarían pese
al clamor de los científicos
el martes se reportó otra cifra récord
pero está expositiva de casi un millón
de terceras dosis aplicadas en este país
para completar un poco más de 30
millones de personas en todo el país que
han recibido esa tercera dosis o dosis
de refuerzo el gobierno johnson se ha
impuesto como medida aplicar esta
tercera dosis a toda la población sobre
los 18 años antes de que termine este